foreign
former president Donald Trump shows up
in court tomorrow he will be appearing
before a judge who has developed a
reputation for coming down especially
hard on January 6 writers by the way why
didn't we ever go after the people
involved in the summer 2020 riots uh
574 of them dozens of dead Americans
thousands of injured cops billions of
property damage anyway she also said
that what happened that day should never
be compared to those 574 riots why not a
riot should never happen any place
anywhere this is the exact same judge
who released all of the Trump White
House Records to the January 6 committee
so if the special counsel is Prosecuting
Donald Trump for challenging the results
of the election
what about all the times the Democrats
did the exact same thing we just
happened to have 45 minutes of tape but
will run only a small portion
I believe he knows he's an illegitimate
president I think it's also
critical to understand that
as I've been telling candidates who have
come to see me you can run the best
campaign
you can even become the nominee
and you can have the election stolen
from you I think he's an illegitimate
president that didn't really win so how
do you you know fight against that in
2020 you are absolutely right the
president is an illegitimate racist
occupying the White House the Russian uh
uh uh weighing in on the election the
Russian attempt to have the election and
frankly the FBI is weighing in on the
election I think make the make it makes
his election illegitimate it's
illegitimate and my biggest fear is that
he's going to do it again with the help
to help and that is terrifying it's
terrifying would you be my vice
president
folks look I absolutely agree we had
this little election back in 2018.
and despite the
final tally and the inauguration and the
situation we find ourselves in I do have
one very affirmative statement to make
we won
I believe
was a stolen election and I'm not saying
they stole it from me they stole it from
the voters of Georgia wow amazing any of
them getting charged now when the
Democrats made those remarks no one was
questioning whether or not they really
believed the statements here with
reaction now you're going to love his
upcoming book it's called the Democratic
party hates America the host of life
liberty Levin right here on the Fox News
Channel the great one Mark Levin
thankfully
by the way Mark was the
um he is the only guest in the history
of cable news that tells a host that's
it I'm done
um
Mark I just want to get your general
thoughts on all of it obviously you got
a lot to say
I want to have a heart to heart here
with you Sean and your audience in
America
you know what's going on in your country
you see what's going on you see we're
unraveling
my greatest concern and I pray I'm dead
wrong
is that the Democrat Party is creating a
combustible situation here
the Democrat Party is destroying our
schools it's destroying parental rights
it's destroying the nuclear family
it's destroying people of Faith it's
gone after the Catholic Church
the Democrat Party is promoting
censorship and all of its departments
and agencies
it's destroying our Traditions uh it's a
strong Law and Order Our police crime is
rampant
our military can't keep up now with
Personnel because it's destroyed our
military or is
and Joe Biden likes to talk about the
bottom-up in the middle out this is a
top-down passive Revolution
passive in the sense that it's not a
violent revolution
but it's the kind of Revolution that
Antonio gramski and Italian communist
and even Lenin talked about
where they take over the institutions of
government they take over the
institutions of the culture and they
impose their will
we now have a government that's Banning
household products from light bulbs to
automobiles in order to control your
life we have a government
that is destroying your lifestyle
driving up the cost of energy it's going
to get worse before it gets better
driving up the cost of food people are
having difficulty making ends meet and
yet their propaganda operation that is
the media
tells you how wonderful things are in
this country according to this statistic
or that statistic
what's happening now is something that
has never happened in American history
in 247 years
not just the indictment of a president
we have a hundred charges against this
president
from a Democrat D.A in Manhattan a
Democrat D.A is about to in Atlanta
a Democrat attorney general in New York
a radical left-wing Rogue prosecutor
would now two grand juries completely
out of control they will use any tool
they can they don't care about Free
Speech they don't care about the Bill of
Rights they don't care about
attorney-client privilege they don't
care about any of it
this is a Democrat Party that is power
hungry
and they see an opportunity right now
to monopolize the government and
politics forevermore
to destroy the effectiveness of the
Republican Party
which is why they keep promoting voting
systems that will ensure that they're
the majority party forevermore
which is why they're trying to make two
areas a territory Puerto Rico and the
district at Columbia State so they'll
have four Democrat Senators forevermore
which is why they attack only the
conservatives on the court and
intimidate them with their mobs and and
threaten them in order to try and get
the decisions they want and threaten
with them with
um with expanding the court in order to
destroy the court
you look at everything that's going on
in this country this is a party that
hates this country this is a party that
in 1857 got behind the Dred Scott
Decision which tore this country apart
and resulted in a civil war and that's
what I fear now
I fear it could be five years 10 years
15 years I don't know and I pray to God
that I'm wrong but look at the
sycophants and surrogates on MSNBC and
CNN how they sneer and they attack tens
of millions of Americans like like we
are white supremacists or klansmen
they're the party of the white
supremacists and the klansmen we're not
we're the ones who defeated them
but take a look at what they're doing to
the country the censorship every
Department of the government from the
White House out bottom up middle out
centering the American people destroying
the language we can't even agree on what
a woman is and a man is destroying our
our colleges and our universities
destroying our Public Schools through
their union bosses and so forth and so
on what they're doing to Donald Trump
here they doing it because they figure
they're going to get away with it who's
going to stop them so we have this
passive top-down Revolution that is
taking place it is anti-American it is
Marxist in name and shape and this
ladies and gentlemen is the problem that
we're confronting hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else